hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so in this video guys i
want to make a daily market update i
will try to do that every day so i'm
going to quickly discuss what is
happening on the spy so the global
market and i want to discuss today as
well what is happening on the energy
sector stocks let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys so we had some crazy moves
yesterday on many stocks so fusa
nine
cei and maybe one more i'm gonna see if
i have time to analyze one more so i
will discuss all of that guys i will uh
see with you why the stocks have surged
if there is still room on the upside
we're gonna analyze the situation
technically and of course we're gonna
have a look at the synthetic short and
regular short interest compared to the
volume to know if we have a squeeze
situation or not first let me quickly
show you guys what is happening in the
global market we lost three percent
yesterday on the spy
uh you guys know my view here i'm having
this chart for maybe two months guys i
mean i have slightly updated when the
waves reach the levels but the levels
have not changed and here guys the
strong move that we had yesterday on
increasing volume not very big increase
as you can see on the spy but it's still
a red day on increasing volume guys it
is not looking like you know a reversal
that is going to happen sooner let me
check quickly what are the futures doing
right now futures are up 70 beeps they
were down
quite a lot guys they just rebounded
they were down one percent now the up 70
bips i think we go over guys i think
this is not finished it's going to be
finished soon but for now we go over the
reason behind guys is of course the
commodity prices are going higher
because of the ukraine russia war we're
going to have the re the fed decision in
one week uh about the interest rates i'm
afraid we're going to have bad news
because the inflation is will kick in
and it's going to impact the growth what
is happening in this conflict is going
to impact the global growth it's not
good for anyone so i think the fed might
actually you know maybe delay the rate
hike maybe inject some more money maybe
they're gonna slow down the tap ring
maybe they even gonna start to buy again
we're gonna see but for now the news
flow is not positive okay so i think
that nothing too bad is going to happen
on the market i don't think we might
really crash
uh because i think the fed will
intervene at the right time so but for
now we are bearish guys and i think we
are going to reach the target so spy at
405 so i see
three three four percent move down to
come more maybe in one week and then a
rebound all right now i want to discuss
with you guys what is happening on the
energy sectors because once again this
war as you guys know is impacting a lot
the community prices we have the oil
price that is trending above
the crude oil above 120 dollars a barrel
uh the gas natural gas is also very
impacted because of course you guys are
aware that russia is a massive player in
this business and and of course uh the
tensions created by the war are
affecting the price so we saw yesterday
a lot of uh energy
related
stocks that
had some crazy crazy moves up guys so i
want to go through those three with you
uh and see what we have here so first
husa not sure how to pronounce it so
houston american energy corporation
moved up by 500
all right so we had a nice move up
that's what we can call uh actually
massive massive move up guys
the market cap was at that time
so who's up was 20 million us dollars
it is now 100 a bit more than 100
million us dollars all right okay so the
market cap is now 112 million us dollars
it's still a small market cap so the
reddit crowd might uh jump into this
trade but
i was discussing that on my discord this
morning and i think it is too late to
get in i don't see a good risk reward
because of course this shoe moves up
guys i mean without any consideration
before
uh the breakout i don't even know if we
can find a breakout somewhere maybe
around two or three
i mean it's a pure gamble now we have
reached the
13 resistance level as you can see it
was the recent high so i think that most
traders will take profits here those who
bought here probably will take profits
you can see guys this i mean what
happened yesterday is a typical
speculative move i mean it's there's
nothing natural in that increase you can
see we had 200 million shares trading
the float share is
8 million
so you basically had
25
times the share float that was traded in
one day so of course a lot of traders
were just buying selling buying selling
taking profits so i don't think it's
reflecting the fundamentals of the
company all right uh which doesn't mean
that the price will not hold it just
means that right now i think
traders will be taking profits around
13. so if we go above 13
because 13 is the resistance level once
again created by the recent high they
might start buying again so it will
depend let's see what is happening today
for now the pre-market is positive we're
around 13. so question i don't know
but if we start to move really higher we
might very well go to 21 which is the
next resistance level so for those who
want to gamble not financial advice a
way to trade that is to buy only on the
way up so if the price trades above what
is 14
have to to to use a stop limit order
above 14 i might be doing that today
because if we start to go higher than
that level everybody's gonna start to
buy again so this is the right way to
trade that it's not good to bite on the
way down because you know the momentum
will prevail in this situation so once
again i think here the only way to trade
that if you are in i mean taking profit
is of course appropriate
uh if not only by if we start to go
higher even maybe above 15 you know to
make sure the momentum is back again
next one i want you to check with you
guys nine then i'm going to check cei
where historically we have some interest
on the stock coming from the reddit
cross crowd so we might see something
happening here first nine so nine energy
service same thing it's uh
quickly but it's a oil related company
oil field services offers onshore
completion and production services and
energy service also focuses on wealth
solutions including cementing
stimulating isolating and drilling
ourselves oil and gas all right
exploration and production okay so
roughly the same thing we had a move up
only of 100
it's of course ironical guys it's a
massive move up here i think the
technicals are a bit cleaner
uh so it's easier to make a trade in
here so
68 million shares traded yesterday
let's analyze a bit what we have here
guys
okay so market cap hundred million
roughly the same thing
we have some shorts on
who said we didn't have any short
interest here same thing i don't see any
option market
oh that's coming sorry okay so here we
have 15
of uh short interest so on who said we
had only four percent so you have more
shots so shorts might be covering as
well on the upside the dtc is below one
so they to cover
which means that shots have time to
cover in terms of volume traded because
the dtc below two or three is not hot
okay and we had so the flood share is 15
million shares and we had 68 million
shares traded yesterday so five times so
less interest than on hussa of course
everybody was there because this is
where we had things happening yesterday
uh let's see today what's gonna happen
maybe we're gonna have some follow-up
here on nine let me check what is the
pre-market doing here oh pre-market plus
50 so indeed we have some follow-up
so we are we are likely to open around
5.5 which is above the resistance level
so yesterday resistance level was around
four
now we are going to open around 5.5 so
right somewhere here
okay
let me check where is the next
resistance
it's around 6.7 okay i just take the
recent high and seeing that here i have
as well one two reactions so i like this
resistance
i could put it at 10
if things really start to get hot let's
be honest we can go to 10 today if if we
have the same kind of move
as we had on the husa yesterday we're
not going to 10. this is where we had
the 200-day moving average
so it's possible we are about to open
higher
i mean buying at the open is not
financial advice guys but it's not a bad
idea
here i think because i think that
everybody's going to be buying all right
i don't see any reason to sell if we
open here so we might just rally guys to
10. so i mean it's of course risky it's
hard to use a stop loss here maybe use a
stop loss below 370 is a nice way so you
risk two points and you can make if you
buy at 550 you you can you can make five
so you have a five
versus two risk reward so 2.5 risk
reward which is very acceptable
and i think that this is a reasonable
target i think it's reachable once again
we have small market cap and we have a
little bit more shorts so shorts
will probably cover right away if i was
short in this market i see an open at
5.5 i cover right away
so yeah what else do we have we have
some options at three but the gamma is
very small so no gamma squeeze here for
sure the option market is not very big
so yeah that's it for nine next one cei
guys so you guys probably heard of this
one because it's more famous i mean i
was following the stock for quite some
time i was here in this move up i took
uh i made some money here i don't
remember where i took profits but i was
in that trade i'm not in it anymore of
course i took profits or i got stopped i
don't remember i might jumped in it
again so here guys same thing
technically it's
more than on
like a 90 day finish yeah i'm done on
nine and on ci technically it's cleaner
as well the reason why okay i'm gonna be
on a weekly time frame
uh so very long term trend lines like
that are you know sometimes not very
efficient but sometimes they are and
here i have one i'm using five years
trend line one two three
four reactions and here a fifth one
yesterday at one point three one point
four so you see this trend line
and this trend line guys we are just
below
and right now it's gonna open
at 143 so just above right just above
the stream line is it higher than
yesterday 147 here i would maybe do the
same thing if only we trade above 150
start to get in okay so you can use not
financial advice a stop limit
uh a buy stop limit order so you only
buy if the price action gets above 100
150 for example let's quickly check what
is here doing of course i have checked
already they are doing pretty much the
same things it's the same kind of sector
operates as an energy company exploits
develops and produces crude oil and
natural gas we are where we should be
exactly here so
let's check quickly what is uh the
market cap we like small market caps
guys once again because there is more
interest from the reddit crowd
and easier to make it move
so market cap here is slightly bigger
guys 380 million us dollars so three
times bigger so the synthetic shot is
not big and the regular shot is 10
so nothing crazy here guys the float
share is 300 million shares and
yesterday we had 600 so you see only
twice so here the volume is lower so
basically it didn't start yet so this
one is to me the one
that
has the most potential
but it's also the one that had the worst
fundamentals so that's the reason why
traders started to buy the ones that
were looking the best
so kusa and nine definitely they're
looking better than ci which you know
value has just dropped 100 guys it lost
everything all right in a couple of two
years so it's
they're really losing a lot of money so
it's harder for a stock like that to
find back the upside momentum but if it
starts to move up
we can see some nice moves happening as
well so here once again only by above
150
this is i think the right thing to do if
you want to get in
stop loss can be put around 0.8 so and
the target can be around four you see so
here the risk reward you can make let's
say about a 1.5 you buy at 1.5 you can
make 2.5 if you buy at 1.5 you risk 0.7
so the risk reward is around 3.3 guys
here so
it's a nice risk reward so this is a
nice trade to do as well and
what else can i say here yeah the short
is ten percent yeah the only problem in
this kind of breakouts guys is that we
don't have any consolidation before the
breakout so those breakouts can also
fade as well last one i wanted to show
you guys uh so it was brought to me by
my guys on discord o e g all right this
one is in the same situation as cei a
little bit you can see we have the trend
line here that is not broken yet
so if we start to trade higher we might
see some bullish momentum taking place
what is the pre-market doing yeah up 11
so i think this is gonna rally today as
well and here the situation is slightly
different we have more short interest on
this market
so schultz can participate in the
bullish momentum as you can see yes we
have 13 of regular short and one percent
of synthetic short so and but the volume
is still low so we have a dtc at 4.4
which is higher than ci and the market
cap is smaller so oeg is better than ci
to me and last thing yesterday 10
million shares exchanged and we have
you see so very small compared to the
shelf float of 50 million so here things
have not started yet
so let's see i'm not saying it's gonna
do the same thing as nine and hussa
which did some crazy moves up i think
the interest is gonna be on those two
today again
but we might slowly see traders taking
profits on those two and you know once
you make money you want to do it again
right some them they might come to oeg
and ci later oig looks better to me same
thing guys here it's better to buy on
the way up and it's in terms of targets
2.8 is the first resistance and if we
are more ambitious
five okay so those are the levels and
the stop loss can be around 1.5
something like that so that's it for me
i hope you guys enjoyed this video once
again i will keep doing some daily
updates today i talked about the energy
tomorrow i'm probably going to talk
again about the energy because this is
what is hot but i want to talk about
what is hot in the market i want to keep
covering the spy triple q i'm going to
switch from one to the other and i'm
going to try to give you guys some daily
updates about what is happening and what
is nice to do so hope you enjoyed this
video and if you did please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore i'll see you guys